you know louisiana is one of the states
being hit hardest by this new surge in
coronavirus cases
the governor says it now has more virus
related hospitalizations now than at
any other point in the pandemic in march
julia ledlow
won a special election to become the
first republican woman from louisiana to
serve in congress
the election was held because her
husband luke died from covet in december
his death came just weeks after he was
elected to the same congressional seat
but he died just a couple of weeks
before he could be sworn in
in an interview that you will see only
on cbs this morning we traveled to
louisiana and i sat down with the
congresswoman
to talk about what her late husband went
through and to get her message
to those people who are still
unvaccinated
he and i had had prayed for weeks prior
about the possibility of the vaccine and
we were so excited that it was coming
out
and that it was going to be widely
available and he missed it by two weeks
congresswoman julia letlow's husband
luke had just been elected to congress
when he got sick he looked at me and
said
honey i feel like i'm running a fever
and my heart sank
he isolated upstairs in their home and
she stayed downstairs with their
children
jacqueline age one in jeremiah 3. he had
no pre-existing conditions
so there was just no reason why
it had to go down that path coughing
nonstop and
by about the eighth day he called me
upstairs and just said
honey i think it's time to go to the
hospital
it's right before christmas and i drove
him
to our hospital here and he cried
on the way because he was upset about
missing christmas with his kids
jacqueline's first christmas and
jeremiah's that he would be able to
remember
by that point she says that 50 of his
lungs were just
filled with covered pneumonia from his
hospital bed luke letlow who was a
former congressional chief of staff
was working the phones like he was known
to do best it got so bad i had to take
the phone away because he wasn't resting
like the doctors were telling him to but
he was having conversations and he was
saying goodbye to people
and telling him he was at peace
and it all happened very quickly where
he was very aware
and cognizant and speaking to people and
then
um kind of crossed over a threshold
where i started to see
the color drain
and that's when it hit me that he might
not come
when the time came to have the talk
about whether to place him on a
ventilator
luke letlow was ready i called his
parents
and they prayed over him called my
parents and they prayed over him and
every night before bed we had this
ritual where we say the blessing of our
children
as they go to bed and that is the lord
bless you and keep you
make his face shine upon you and be
gracious unto you i give you peace
and i set that over him those are the
last words
and i told him i loved him and i kissed
him goodbye and i was washing his feet
you know and for christians that can be
very
really symbolic and i had no idea
that i was preparing him and how special
that moment was
for both of us right now the
congresswoman state of louisiana
is seeing its worst surge yet in coconut
infections
and hospitalizations and she started to
take a look at the statistics in her own
district
in northern and central louisiana with
few exceptions
every parish falls below 30 percent
fully vaccinated not from lafayette
right
are some of the folks who were listening
to everybody but the doctors
what do you say to them people don't
want to
feel forced into anything they don't
want to be lectured to
they don't you know we are a very
prideful strong people in louisiana
i just said what what can i do is there
anything i could do
to help with the misinformation out
there with all of the
confusion and fear and
and someone asked well what would you
what would you tell somebody who was on
the fence about possibly receiving the
vaccine
and i said i'd tell them about luke i
would tell him my story
so she and her team started thinking
what could they do
to memorialize the stories of kovid's
victims
there's power in stories and so we
we talked about it and said well well
let's put together
this bill it's the covid 19 american
history
uh project act that will provide a space
to collect
those stories for the library of
congress i would have given
anything i would have given everything
for that shot to be available for us
i mean looking back now and for someone
to turn it away
i just it it's heartbreaking to me
luke lutlow is buried under this cedar
tree next to his grandfather
in start louisiana my plot is right next
to him and all i want is a little foot
stone that says
and she followed up the congresswoman
now splits her time
between washington d.c and home in
northeastern louisiana
let's go let's go find them as she moves
forward raising
their two children if the vaccines were
to become available
for children as young as your kids would
you get them vaccinated
on the first day my prayer is that not
one
more person has to lose their life to
this virus
it is a horrific way to leave this world
i don't wish it on anyone else
we have the answer let's use it
we also talked about all of the
misinformation that she says some of her
constituents are buying into
about vaccines and that misinformation
she says
was really hard for her in the middle of
all her grief the congresswoman says she
literally sat down
and went through hateful messages
directed to her husband on social media
saying that no he didn't die of coverty
died of a heart attack or something else
and she literally deleted those
because she said i couldn't stand to
continue reading them she's hoping that
what you just heard her story his story
might change your opinion i sure hope so
david i'm just struck by in the middle
of all that
she's he she he are getting hateful
comments
yeah that's true that's what just blows
me away and i look at the children who
i think will remember their father and
that he had
no underlying conditions that's what's
so scary about kovid
had no underlying conditions whatsoever
none two weeks before the vaccine came
out he was going to get it
yeah he was arrested that's interesting
yeah he was gonna get it he was going to
get it yeah well she and she sums it up
right at the end
we have the answer let's use it in fact
she said he wanted to have a press
conference from his hospital bed
really to let people know his
constituents know
how real the virus was my heart aches
for her because you can really feel her
pain but you also see her strength
and her commitment now into helping
others that was really really a
beautiful story
congresswoman thank you for sharing your
story thank you